hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley
baby here we go again gang hey everybody
out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show we sit
down with your favorite comedians
and find out if they go up classy or if
they're complete trash i'm your host
holy coming at you on a beautiful fall
day here in new york city
in the east village gas digital studios
in the big studio
you can feel the crisp in the air made
an apple pie this weekend ate the whole
thing in one night
not shocked about it my co-host coming
at you from right next to me
he yelled at me before the show just
somebody knows he's [ __ ] cranky i
don't know if the hymns aren't working
or what the deal is
kid's backed up he's got to whack one
out gotta send him to a rubbing tug
get this kid fresh yeah but gang when
you reach for a best battle do yourself
a favor still
even after all that you make it to kippy
kevin james ryan everybody hey gang i
would like to not apologize for my
outburst earlier the whole booth was on
my side i must say
we're gonna be taking applications for
new co-hosts moving forward on ru
garbage and already garbage enterprises
thank you so much for listening
everybody uh shout out we
appreciate uh make sure you uh subscribe
bringing review on itunes do it
full video available on youtube you can
subscribe there unless that's [ __ ]
six thousand we'll be at six thousand by
the time this comes out we appreciate
that uh also uh if you want um all the
benefits of gas digital network all the
last episodes i mean we've had [ __ ]
everybody we've had
norman lish schultz versi bobby kelly
who else
drawing blank we have [ __ ] everybody
couple guys all those are available on
gasdigitalnetwork.com if you can sign up
using promo code ayg
we get to wet our beaks a little bit we
make a couple of bucks you save a couple
of bucks it's a win-win for everybody
so [ __ ] sign up guys thanks not too
shabby gang i say this often but this
time it's 100
true we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly funny incredibly
special guest
here with us today he's a stand-up
comedian and actor as an actor some of
the things he has appeared in is inside
amy schumer marin
and those who can't as a stand-up
comedian
where do you hear this [ __ ] rap sheet
laundry list late night with jimmy
fallon
this is not happening he's got his own
half-hour comedy central special
all right it's been on two episodes of
conan brody stevens enjoy it
at midnight all right uh
the today's show the meltdown what's
your [ __ ] deal
comedy knockout live at the apartment
this week at the comedy cellar
he's got two albums out standard
operating procedure and scuttlebutt
but the big question anybody's dying
today is he garbage
and i stumbled over that like a [ __ ]
stroke victim like he does every week
i apologize ladies and gentlemen give me
a nice [ __ ] big round of applause for
the one the only the incredible
mr sean patton everybody you guys
you guys have such great voices
like you know it feels like you're the
like the two radio djs
who just know don't know the 90s is over
yes
we're not hiring these two guys and then
podcasts started happening
yeah and then they were like oh my god
look now they're emperor
sometimes sometimes i hear it i'm like
like we you really could just call us
like [ __ ] fatso and baldi and we
could like take over cleveland for sure
i i don't i i i didn't i did not go that
far
fatso and baldi which that's
why why why is that the where it's
skewed with morning radio
it all went like what it all went into
like whoa we're crazy guys who we eat
garbage
i know and we're drunk all the time like
why didn't it skew into more like
hey look i i would you know what i was
doing last night reading proud
who else was up reading that one book by
the way where are my intellectuals at
call in uh the [ __ ] that's uh
wait it's funny because you said live at
the apartment i did i couldn't read my
handwriting i
stumbled over but for a second i thought
you were about to say live at the apollo
and i had a moment me too did i do that
i probably got yanked off
immediately the only guy ever beat up
the sandman ladies and gentlemen i
forgot you know what that was that was a
show
at an apartment before shows and
apartments happened
yeah yeah virus i missed i missed best
bars in america that's
how you can leave that you can always
leave that now well we had your co-host
on james yeah
that show uh that show destroyed both of
us from the liver out there's a lot of
boozing right
a lot of boozing and a lot of dealing
with uh
[ __ ] i mean if you're gonna let
if you're gonna do a show that takes
place in a bar they should i think they
should have let us run a little wilder
yeah yeah yeah they tried they tried to
hone us in a little too much and was
like
you want me to repeat myself i'm
hammered
why are the [ __ ] where are the camera
guys doing and the camera guys are doing
their job i don't i don't wanna it
wasn't anybody's fault but it was just
uh
also we were both like i think
i think if you're going to have a show
where your guys are drinking every
single [ __ ] week
like that's the thing multiple bars a
day
so you're drinking from we would start i
would say 2 p.m
to 3 a.m sometimes damn what and
multiple bars
usually two and a half hours at each bar
and you couldn't fake it
you couldn't yeah so it comes off so in
general so generous and you just
couldn't fake it
but you couldn't sober up either because
then you would just
get that like the sleeping the head the
heavy head heavy yeah
she kind of had to maintain a buzz i get
it now i now i'm just describing
your average resident of chicago or new
orleans
i get it but like i don't know having to
be professional in those moments
that's the part no one understood
they're like greatest job in the world
once something becomes the job though
that's not fun it's not fun
and so get so getting shit-faced stopped
being fun yeah because you had to
maintain some level of like
oh i'm sorry i got to say this to the
camera this is a great way
[ __ ] it just this this drink sucks
sounds to me like you need it was a
little [ __ ] nose candy to keep it
keep you on
believe you me it was offered but jay's
a family man
and i am a [ __ ] i'm not i'm not talking
about going crazy just a little tudor
utsuki to get you back on [ __ ] get you
back on the runway get your head
straight
but that's don't you find with
tudorooski
[Laughter]
that would have been your name that
would have been part of your segment
it's tudorowski tuesdays how did you get
to insert drop of snorting yeah
but anyway yeah it was that but that was
just interesting hearing some of that
stuff because like
at midnight i forgot that i forgot that
show remember that show yeah that was
like hot for a minute it was like that
was like a get like she wanted to get on
adventures
some people were great i was [ __ ]
terrible like puns are my weakness but
like
some people were [ __ ] like ron
funches was just like a jedi yeah
but i remember you'd show up and there
there'd be writers who just had like a
list of options to choose from
really yeah and you'd be like yeah
please yeah
i don't have to do anything with me yeah
but then you did that then that
like ego would take control and you'd be
like no no no yeah what are you doing
you're a comedian come up with your own
she'd be like all right i said i wanted
ten give me
three yeah and i'll come up with the
other seven yeah keep them in your
pocket just bloodcast yeah but like that
i forgot about that
that was big remember i remember when i
first got to the city every people were
doing red eye that was like a big deal
getting on that show
with tom shalou yeah it was that on fox
conservative
at midnight that's all
so it was so it was at 8pm
[Laughter]
too funny all right so we want to hear
the back story about sean patton we
you and i did uh shannon's podcast a few
uh a few months ago which is really fun
and one of the stories that you told
which is a ghost story which was [ __ ]
frightening
but the story started out with him and
one of his boys
in the woods boozing yeah man so oh yeah
we know where we're going in this
direction do you think you're garbage
i you know what i think i'm a i think
i'm i call myself i
i come from here i come from southeast
louisiana from
you know the suburbs of new orleans we
weren't white trash we were quite
recyclable
oh that's i think i think that's what
we're going to discover at the end of
this podcast that i'm a recyclable okay
but
so a hybrid where was your uh
socio-economic level as compared to like
norman
because his was like real weird like
they lived in the mansion but they were
broke and it was a shitty neighborhood
well define the suburbs mark
actually like like my parent my family's
from the lower ninth
like legit hardcore like uh
core of new orleans okay uh but they you
know got out at certain point and i
i grew up in slidell louise chalmette
and slidell which together
are like the staten island okay mark
to my knowledge grew up in like mark
actually grew up in the city he grew up
in like the
alphabet city yeah like proper yeah yeah
um
i mean i don't i don't know what mark's
parents did for a living i would say we
were like
we were upper middle class for sure okay
nobody was shrimping or anything like
that
i mean my my mom for a living no
my mom's nurse my mom's an rn all right
and my dad
runs a catering business okay so like we
you know we did well but we lived in the
[ __ ]
you know the i i i liked
i i know it's like [ __ ] hip to [ __ ]
on the suburbs you can't
of course it's a show it's i mean it's
so hip to just
trash your past and i suffered so hard
but no i mean
i lucked out like my inner my immediate
family were good people
okay and we were and we we grew up in
like a
a a middle-class nub suburb that thought
it was a lot
more badass like gotcha that's a lot of
the suburbs that's a lot of suburbs it
was
like there was a country club in my
neighborhood but it was a working-class
country club like i learned to play
tennis
but from a dude named renee who had an
lsu tiger tattoo on his
tongue on his [ __ ] tongue he wore
lsu gear every louisiana state
university every single day
he would watch games at the country club
and he was that guy who
and you know sports fans they'd be
watching he'd be watching like look at
this is great third and ten and then if
there's a fumble
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
you [ __ ] fumble like dark you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
anyway yeah so he was that see your
overhand serve again there sean
and here's the best part didn't attend
louisiana
state university oh my god that's a
trash quality crash
but that's but you know what i'm saying
so like i was surrounded by guys like
that and my dad
like i said runs a catering company the
thing about a catering company is and
i'm not trying to but 70
of the workforce in the catering company
is part-time
yeah yeah yeah for sure 70 of those
people
are kind of on their last chance yes yes
yes yes you know what i'm saying it's
not a second chance maybe cons or
something a little checkered past
or like senior citizens who don't need
the money but just need to move so their
bodies don't shut down
yeah yeah so like or both and also
ex-convicts yeah but so like you're i
was surrounded my
whole life by like the the underbelly
the knuckleheads the knuckleheads
but you learn a lot from that yes that's
what the whole show is from of course my
whole family is knuckleheads
it's like my mom's one of there's
hundreds of us there's she's 109 from
philadelphia they're all like
[ __ ] plumbers or they're all just
like blue collar yeah screaming at the
eagles knuckleheads
which i love i know for a fact the
hardest
manual labor in manual labor centers the
hardest workers on the on the planet
are functional alcoholics oh dude i was
just out
questioning you you get a good alcoholic
line cook
oh that guy that guy is good that guy
can [ __ ] up a a a
tomato [ __ ] you know what i mean dude
you go we were just i was he just picked
him up on 57th street and there's like
people outside
all construction workers drinking at
lunch and they're all gonna go back to
like
operating a crane or a forklift or
something they're all having heinekens
out on the streets and they're gonna do
a good job yes
like my dad catered there's a pga
uh event in new orleans every year right
like
on the tour yeah my dad catered that
every year
that's pretty classy it was yeah it's
gotta be a big contract but that's what
it is but that's what i'm saying like
it's all these corporate sky boxes all
these like
[ __ ] you know big money people and my
dad
ran ran an iron [ __ ] ship but
occasionally
you'd have you'd have the guy who's his
whole job is
running giant gallons of food on his
back
back and forth for 16 hours straight
that guy's nipping a budweiser
that guy's got a steady low but steady
buzz
yeah the whole time like a low grade
fever right his name's his name's aj
and he's a good [ __ ] guy you know
what i mean he's a good [ __ ] dude
can you blame him yeah not at all and
they all got that louisiana accent like
though he just got to [ __ ] suck it
down right quick
and you don't let him see you do it but
you know do also just put it down
you know just put it down somebody's
like is that yours i ain't mine i ain't
touching it
very loud street corner mentality yeah
that's who the boss usually looks the
other way if you're a hard worker they
get away with as long as you're not
[ __ ] embarrassing anybody you're not
grabbing at tiger woods his wife
right i think i think i mean tiger woods
didn't go to that
he didn't stop it that way we got
you got phil mickelson maybe yeah you
got you got a lot of john daly's
but like uh no offense john daly but you
know come on guy could hit real hot a
guy was like
you're trash he's trash yeah yeah yeah
he has talked about [ __ ] crack in the
safe that guy
infiltrated like the most prestigious of
prestigious sports
and he's a [ __ ] he's a booz smoking
darts on the
yeah but just so you know we love the
burbs we celebrate it here yeah i mean
we love it we celebrate it and like when
i was home for [ __ ] i went home for a
little bit for the pandemic yeah
half of me in the back of my head like
this is [ __ ] nice down here
i mean yeah dude i mean i'm i'm
definitely first generation
suburb right like my parents oh yeah
yeah my parents are city
but like that's the thing because of
that the rest of my fam most of my like
a large chunk of my family is still in
the city so i spent
most of my upbringing up in the city
right and then like as soon as i get the
[ __ ] out i did
and like you know one of my sisters
lives back in the burbs now but only
because she could afford to buy a house
there
okay because houses in [ __ ] the city
of new orleans pre pandemic i don't know
what they're like now
or you know you know skyrocketing yeah
and i think that's a lot of cities it's
like weird because there was white
flight
yeah and then now i don't know
gentrification and then the cities are
like
popular again but now there's this whole
group of people who are like we want to
live in the city
we have the jobs that are in the cities
but we can't afford yeah to live in the
city so they're like moving back
right into like the closest suburbs now
and it's like a different form of it's
like forced flight
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that doesn't see color
[Laughter]
how many brothers and sisters do you
have i have two sisters and a brother
i'm the oldest
okay oh really yeah go figure this by
how much
i mean uh four years four years
nine years 14 years wow wow so you were
like the [ __ ]
you were like the big bear you were you
were watching out for all them
you know what like i said earlier where
i
learned basically by being surrounded by
so many
you know uh so much so much salt
so the salt and the salt of the earth to
the point where it was giving
the earth hypertension yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i i learned i'm talking about
himalayan right
now we're talking about mortons
we're talking about guys right right
we're talking about the sidewalk salt
necessarily on food yeah the non-edible
salt
it burns the dog's feet that's the kind
of salt we're talking about but like
because of that i learned
a lot of what not to do in life and i
think i provided the same service
for my siblings yeah i was a total [ __ ]
up i was just
from like 16 to 20. i was a
piece of [ __ ] just like boozing and
drinking
skipping school stealing from my parents
lying about it uh getting caught went to
jail
uh for playing mailbox baseball like all
real good [ __ ] holy [ __ ] i know that's
like
that's like stand by me type [ __ ] dude
it was it was
like you had soda pop seriously i
remember
it was me and two other guys and we
didn't do it from like the back of a
truck we did it from like the window of
my buddy's car and we were just
driving around side out hitting
mailboxes drunk got our minds high as
[ __ ]
and we decided to get his ex-girlfriend
but vengeance right the problem was we
did it
too late slash early in the morning to
where her parents were up
heard the commotion recognized his car
sure and they called the cops if we'd
have been
they dimed out they dimed us out but
[ __ ] up dude if we'd have
it's a federal offense let's say if it
had been an hour later and there was
mailbox
or mail in those mailboxes we'd have
been [ __ ] that's the difference that's
the difference a [ __ ] pottery barn
catalog you get your federal charges
it's like shooting somebody below the
kneecap
yeah it's not attempted murder oh really
yeah keep that one in your back
pocket next
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] yeah i went to [ __ ]
that was actually the greatest thing my
parents ever did for me was they left me
in jail
really i got arrested on a monday
morning uh
and it got processed and that's you know
if you've ever been through it this is
for the
for the mailbox baseball yeah okay they
didn't come get me they called my
they called the house i'm like bring
them in or we're coming to get them now
how did the parents know that you were
in the car with the kids because the
[ __ ] kid who was driving the car
snitched everyone out
and here's the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
where's best this is the
nobody's in 1997. nobody wrapped i
wasn't in vogue yet
honestly i'm surprised just pretty
takashi it's just gonna stitch back down
nobody did i'm surprised
that the parents [ __ ] called the cops
and they didn't normally
for in my situation that would have been
the mom
would have called my mom and gave a
warning
because i actually had that situation i
was leaving some messages on an
ex-girl's
voicemail that weren't too nice they
weren't please return my hoodie either
dude
i love i love the idea people snitched
in the 80s
yeah the 90s were clean yeah right
people had honor there's a coat of
gentleman
they were all the [ __ ] people they
would have called your mom and said
listen if he does this again then i'm
gonna
you know we're calling we're gonna call
him the cop how's this again if he
commits another felony we're really
gonna get people started snitching in
the arts no i mean like
i also think you wanna you wanna live in
like goodfellas in your head a little
bit
i'm telling you nobody did that that's
the way we handled it but the thing was
they dig up and start talking about yeah
they called the cops on the dude
cops came to his house well here's the
[ __ ] thing he was seven he was 17 me
and the other guy were 18
when this happened so the cops couldn't
arrest him he was still
technically a minor yeah so we we go in
the other me and the other guy i mean i
remember like
they read me the rights you know my
mom's there [ __ ] crying
the processing you know which if you've
been through it it's all like i'm in the
system it's crazy but like
um and then you go everyone everyone was
like your parents are going to bail you
out don't [ __ ] fret
and i called them with my one phone call
just to check in and be like
when's the bail going through and i
remember my dad
yeah but i can remember i could hear my
mom crying and my dad in the background
being like we're not bailing you out
dude that's blue collar that's like that
we are not that's just let them [ __ ]
sweat it out
because i was arraigned on a it was
monday morning i got arrested and i got
arraigned on thursday morning
when did you do this what was he he had
to do right right i did it on no we did
it on sunday night sunday night sunday
night in the monday into monday yeah was
it a school night
no it's summertime oh so it's just like
pure [ __ ] up and uh it's weird on a
sunday i don't know
it was because it was also like
unplanned it was they're smashing
mailboxes yeah you care what the [ __ ]
day it is it seems like more of like a
friday saturday night thing
baby yeah that's why we did it on a
sunday yeah i'm guessing he was
outsmarting each
other the campus never be looking for it
see yeah
don't ever get us on a sunday god damn
it they got it every loser hits a
mailbox on a friday
you eat a bread truck on a friday
mailbox on a sunday do mailboxes on
sundays
you do liquor stores on [ __ ] tuesdays
that's when they want you yeah
they're looking out on a saturday night
yeah
you steal bikes any day of the week yeah
but uh
yeah misdemeanor they they i spent
basically three nights in jail three
days in jail and what was this this is
what this
is the township or whatever you slide
out parish prison or whatever slido
i mean it was just like a [ __ ] basic
four cell
shower at the end rough company i would
imagine no it look i
i lucked out in the sense that it was
myself and the other guy that i was with
oh your buddy
that's awesome so what are you in here
for huh well no but we were it was two
of us in a four-person cell
okay okay well at least the [ __ ]
happened and then yeah and then the
other guy in the cell
he kind of took a liking to us in the
right way
not in like the boy you're gonna be on
my side but just like i see a lot of
myself and you guys and i mean that the
proper way [ __ ]
it's so funny because the dude i wish i
could remember it verbatim
but he was an older guy his name was
ricky which is a
standard yeah standard like
honored trash titles
anything with a y anything that ends in
a y after 20. that is a tough one you
got to go i always
yeah those are just two e's
i always love those situations where
somebody that's like a complete fuck-up
is like giving you the advice yeah
it's like i'm [ __ ] 12. you're 35
we're working in the same kitchen
what are you talking about dude he i'm
he had this he was he he was he told us
that he had turned himself
in he was a speed addict who had turned
himself in
nice uh because he got dude he had the
[ __ ]
it was just such like a man speed it's
good [ __ ] i was on it and then i was off
it and it wore off so now i'm speeding
the car because i ain't speeding in my
head no more and i get pulled over
and i'm running i run i get away i run
and i get away but i realize that's it
that's the only time i'm getting away i
got to turn around i got to turn myself
in dude right
that's why i'm here now man and then he
would lift up his mattress and under his
mattress he had like cigarettes
little chocolates how long was he in
there he had been in there like a month
what yeah he was waiting on his
arraignment which i guess just kept
getting pulled back
jesus so he's been there for like a
month so he just had like a bunch of
[ __ ] under the mattress
uh he smoked half of our cigarettes
because they let us both
have cigarettes they're like you guys
can take your cigarettes in and he
bummed even though he had a [ __ ]
spread yeah
we were way too afraid to be like hey
man you got a [ __ ]
i see five menthols two 100s and a capri
a little skinny guy what the [ __ ] you
taking my camel red lights for
but yeah but it was it i was never like
in danger there was never like a scuffle
or a [ __ ]
there was like a rotating cast of the
fourth member sure of the shell and it
would but you got numbers at that point
like it's you three living harmoniously
if he comes in they're the outside oh
yeah we were definitely yeah but
the the feeling of incarceration was
like nah [ __ ] that
damn like it like i think if my parents
would have bailed me out
i would have by now been dead or just a
total
[ __ ] loser okay but the fact that
sitting in there for
72 hours just the worst feeling of it
drinking the [ __ ] non-carbonated root
beer
oh i just remember that was not
carbonated because it was powdered
so it was powdered root beer flavored
water and it was every meal
was that an a w
a store to hang anything a lot of
bologna
but hey judge how about a mug you know
what i mean
he got agrees to get a [ __ ] to get a
barks in here
i mean orcs has the bite no coffee
there's no caffeine i'm going to go
right to sleep
but yeah it's just again that that was a
very big like all right i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna
get i'm not gonna go down that bath and
so you gotta rain well what did they end
up charging you with i want to hear the
ending i got oh i got uh i mean i got
charged for destruction of property
and got sent introduced to one year
probation
three months of uh community service
service which was
barely i don't remember really doing
anything i remember showing up
and sitting in a room with a bunch of
other fuck-ups and they just
occasionally be like you and you go uh
meet up put on these vests and go
i think like once or twice i had to go
pick up trash like
at a football field in a school after a
game
it was never anything it felt like real
in louisiana i would have been worried
about ending up on a [ __ ] road gang
or something like that
not at night luke i'm sure those guys
i'm sure that happened
i'm sure that's where ricky went
i'm sure he's out there right now
telling his speed story please go [ __ ]
man
breaking bad y'all seen this yet i'm
from the future now i'm back
it's crazy i was on speed off speed on
speed speed on speed off speed down here
god damn but yeah like that that's great
and then yeah i got but i was a [ __ ] up
i mean like my siblings definitely
are all better off because they watch me
just
fall scared them straight i mean the
fights the fights i had with my parents
my mom punched me in the face in front
of all of them once
nice me and my dad went at it once in
front of him i mean the [ __ ] i
shouted the awful [ __ ] things i said
to my parents alone
uh i should [ __ ] burn for you know
stole their van once wasn't the catering
van
no just like their conversion like the
the family training you had a conversion
like a big conversion yeah remember
those [ __ ] things
wow really it was like the one family
vehicle that was clean living back in
the day
the bed went down in the back dad went
down the back captain chairs
captain chairs dude you had captain hook
the team had the built-in tv
with the the dvd player dvd player yeah
i know
it was a big thing like [ __ ] and i
stole it and i stole it
i stole it of course my parents kicked
me out of the house
this was a year oh this is like six
months after
the the jail yeah jesus uh this was like
my relapse they kicked me out of the
house
i snuck back into the house that night
stole the van and had it for like two
days
damn before i finally just brought it
back they didn't call the cops on you
though
they did all right they did they did but
they didn't they just said the van was
stolen they didn't say it was me
but then i left turn it back in and they
called it like it was a mistake and cops
let it go i guess but
i guess i don't really i don't really
know the details that because by that
point i was in a straight up like i got
to get my [ __ ] together
or it's over what'd you do with the van
for two days just literally partied yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's a convertible what do you mean what
the [ __ ] are you not gonna do in a
conversion van with a dvd player
captain chair that's that's the thing
this is why i still to this day suspect
that they didn't actually call the cops
maybe they told me after the fact that
they did
uh but it was it was yeah it was a [ __ ]
up
but damn conversion vans were [ __ ]
conversion
dude i mean like that i wish to god
that they for the ford motor company
still man still made like with the
remember the curtains that pulled yeah
what am i an [ __ ] come on of course
the curtain was in the back when it had
the little ladder
the metal ladder that went up to the top
yeah jesus you guys do know
you guys dude big conversion bank guys
we borrowed one time to we borrowed one
of my dad's business partners conversion
vans one time
to go to niagara falls and i dude i
thought we were
[ __ ] i thought we were the rockefellers
for the weekend it was [ __ ]
awesome man conversion man friday i'm
like i'm like we got the vhs the whole
thing
he's giving us the vhs too all right
let's go yeah conversation wait did you
guys have the chairs that spun
no because captain chairs yeah they
didn't did they spin back
i mean i remember you could do this yeah
yeah yeah that's how i remember
that's like star trek that was [ __ ] well
we had the thing where it turned and
then the table popped up in between the
two
yeah yeah i didn't have that because i
remember that from the 18 when george
papad would turn around and straighten
everybody out
you're in the back with a big stone and
the cooler in the middle
full of always full of bacardi breezers
remember those i don't even know what a
breezer is who was one of them your
parents my mom that was a wine cooler i
do
that was the first sit no see grimsby
the first thing i ever drink bottles and
james yeah wine coolers are to white
claw
what am radio was the podcast exactly
yes
yes for sure nobody gave it nobody gave
them their respect nope
they were after they were 25 years ahead
of the curve
they were they were [ __ ] white claws
with sugar in them
shelters yeah now there's so many i mean
that right there might tell you if i'm
trash or not but i
[ __ ] with seltzer's heart i love them
big
big shelter guy love him but the thing
is
i've never done not i've i've never done
meth yeah but like it's such cheap it's
a weird thing to say
i wish the episode would just end there
and that's the end
that sounds like a guy who's done that
no i'm just saying everybody's made it i
drink a lot i have a drinking bra i
drink a bunch right do you
well like when i drink i drink okay you
don't look like you look like someone
who used to drink but is now sober but
for a while i'm only 19. does that
mean i had a rough paper out of here
he has sober face that's pretty good so
a lot of black coffee and cigarettes
outside of the church um
in an undescript paper cup on a
wednesday night i normally don't drink
coffee or smoke
outside the church in the eyes of god
god i don't know why
i squat wait where are you you guys are
both like philly guys
outside of philly yeah um but meth
never done it but they use they're
cranking those things out now and they
use such cheat it's just cheap malt
liquor and seltzer that's why it was
vodka no
some of one or two like the high noons
actual real vodka but most of them are
just real the cheapest
[ __ ] malt liquor they can get mixed
with seltzer and a little bit of
watermelon or whatever it's all packed
so you drink like [ __ ] 19 of them bad
boys
dude you wake up the next day [ __ ]
suited
you're on mars when you make up when you
wake up dude you're like
i'm like you feel that you feel dirty
the next morning i find myself
checking my heartbeat in my temple
because my shit's gone up into my
[ __ ] head
72
give me a bot i'll drink a bottle of
jameson and i'll get up in the next
morning and run
run a [ __ ] marathon but yeah [ __ ]
20 of them bad boys i'm done
i was drinking four lokos for a minute i
mean they're not that flashy year and a
half
my you know my favorite brand of the uh
zelda is
bud light i think the oh the lights are
nice the bud lights
lights are nice superior yeah we are all
trash
they're all i mean yeah so here i mean
good i'm just feeling this
i'm coloring in this sketch
hey what's up everybody i wanted to tell
you about our new sponsor
cushy dreams we've been waiting to get
these guys on board and i'm happy we did
oh yeah cushy dreams has high quality
cbd bud
it's awesome if you're a fan of cbd it's
great me and me and the big man do it
i got into it a couple of years ago ship
the samples boys
ship them takes the edge off it's
awesome it tastes great and it's
exactly like high quality weed but
without the weed it's awesome you smoke
it it's great
there's a lot of favorite blends you can
choose from you can use it to relax you
can use it for pain management whatever
it is personal
you know i use it personally for uh
anxiety you know what i mean i take a
little edge off in the morning a little
edge off at night
and i hear a lot of people are smoking
less weed when they smoke cushy drinks
really balances it out it's kind of like
a little placebo for weed a little bit
it's great
and also to mention all right grown in
the usa
100 ham trim never no machines are
touching this get them out of here
they cushy dreams takes an artisan
approach all right everything's run in a
small batch
independent lab testing compliance
purity
each batch is slow cured all right
preserves the flavor
preserves the cannabis i'm telling you
cbd is a [ __ ] game changer
for me yeah as far as my anxiety goes so
get on the [ __ ] cushy dreams train
and if you're a pothead when you open up
one of these cans you'll instantly
realize that it's high quality bud
cushy dreams ships legally to all 50
states
and is cbd cannabis that isn't going to
get you high i repeat
it does not get you high it's just a
different way to take your cbd
you want to make me feel good yeah it's
very very nice
i stand by it it is great stuff
so go to cushydreams.com and use promo
code garbage
for how many how many percent off do you
think foley five ten
five i would say we're talking twenty
they're doing
20 off giving the [ __ ] store away
over there that's that's our boys at
cushy dreams
use promo code garbage for 20 off once
again that's cushydreams.com
for high quality cbd bud and if you use
promo code
garbage you're going to get 20 off now
back to the show
unbelievable but yeah it was a [ __ ] up
forever and then uh
i dropped out of school twice like i
dropped out of high school got my ged
high school you dropped you got a ged i
have a ged i have a general education
department because one of the questions
isn't we're curious did you take the
sats uh
louisiana wasn't mandatory it wasn't
like that dude they played fast and
loose in the big easy
yeah it was like amanda's [ __ ] not
mandatory at all
dude tell me about it i don't worry
about it yeah
yeah you're a good kid yeah you're a
good [ __ ] get in here i took the i took
the act
okay and was it scored high enough that
with the acd
act and ged you're able to go to i could
i went to baton rouge community college
okay for a year and a half and then
dropped out again so it was like a
double [ __ ] you to my parents
of like i like how you did a year and a
half of community college i was like
yeah this ain't for me
you're like three months away from
[ __ ] getting i'm outta here i barely
[ __ ] did i was i've
school was it sucks to admit that but
like i also have like mass
i have i have obsessive compulsive
disorder which tends to
draw your attention away sure from that
which isn't something you can completely
obsess about
so school was just something i was never
gonna do yeah i hate it luckily all my
siblings are pretty [ __ ] great at it
and they were they they all did well but
like
like my sis one of my sisters has a
masters um and you know like that and
i remember i remember when she got that
i was like that makes up for me
she's got two degrees we shared so we
each got one if you look at that thanks
aaron
yeah but aaron let me borrow your
bachelor's real quick
yeah i got a job interview by the time i
was like in my like mid-20s though
everything was good like i was doing
comedy by then like my parents i didn't
let my parents come
see me until i like i was doing it for
about four years oh wow
i kept it i mean they knew i was doing
it but i just kept them away i'm like
nope
i think i was kind of that makes sense
that you said when you when you started
doing comedy is when you
i think it's you have a lot of i was the
same way i was just like [ __ ] eating
and drinking and smoking
cigarettes like a [ __ ] oh yeah like
like i was like a [ __ ] tin knocker
for you know my early 20s and i was just
[ __ ] insanely out of shape just no
direction just [ __ ] floating and then
i found comedy and i'm like
oh and then when you're like hyper
focused on something for so long
you straighten up and the distractions
you're not trying to fill your time
anymore with like
booze and [ __ ] you have a purpose you
feel like you finally have a purpose
yeah like i like my parents and i
became cool i didn't like i don't think
my parents and i were
cool till i was like in my mid-twenties
yeah like right to like katrina hit me
did you did you move quickly in comedy
like when did you start to like
i mean i stayed in new orleans for too
long i stayed in new orleans like four
and a half years doing it just because
and like in back then in the city in new
orleans
if you were good you got up maybe twice
a week tops
because there just wasn't that much to
do but we didn't know any better and
there was like a small group of us and
like a handful that were really good
and cared and put on our own shows so
you're getting up maybe eight nine eight
eight
eight to nine times a month yeah but but
we thought that was that was like you're
like i'm doing it
yeah and so i did that for like four and
a half years and then the storm kind of
like made you
you know i was i decided to get out
before the storm hit but also like that
kind of just
shuttled it um i don't know i think i
like because i moved to la first for a
year
and then here and i feel like it was
until i was here for a bit that i
felt truly comfortable in my skin doing
it because i think you got to just eat
it for a while and
yeah yeah yeah and also like have your
have i think
i think the secret to comedy that no one
i don't know why people more comics
don't talk about this it's having your
resolve tested
i think that's 100 and and by that i
mean when you're on a hot streak
when you're younger a comedy you know
three to five years in
and you're crushing it for like a few
months and you're just the hot [ __ ]
and then you have that set where for no
explicable reason you eat ass
and it's a perfect situation why the
[ __ ] and it's not like
you're doing it in front of a bunch of
[ __ ] outside in a park
barely paying attention like we're doing
now but like you're in a packed room
full of people
at a show table set the stakes there
everything's in place for you to be the
[ __ ] sultan of comedy and you [ __ ]
crumble
it's having those moments and coming
back from those because i know lots of
people
who are funnier than i am who are just
straight up
funnier than i am who but they couldn't
come back from those moments well that's
i i think and
yeah you keep going like that it's true
yeah you also have to like when you
start i look back at like people like
just like even in the scene when you
start getting things
quickly yeah like i was doing this show
or it passed at this club and it's like
if you if you have a bunch of quick open
doors yeah
and then you finally hit a wall it's
like it's a lot harder to overcome that
wall
is it the person who's had it like jump
over the walls every [ __ ] well
especially here when i when i moved here
i moved here in 2007
for like the first three years i was
here i didn't [ __ ] with clubs at all
yeah none of us did like a lot of us
were all comedy or
ballroom kids because those were the
better shows back then
yeah and the problem was that it like at
now the clubs have just
there's a renaissance and the clubs are
[ __ ] great the clubs are in new york
are [ __ ] amazing i love
being fortunate enough to do clubs here
is great but like at a club
you can have a rough set and the club's
not going to hold it against you because
you've got two more the next night or
that week but with the bar shows
if you ate ass at one of those a good
one
you know there was a ripple yeah it's
gonna be a while before you're back
because it's just the one show and it's
weekly yeah so it's like hey so it was
like
[ __ ] like so there was a lot of those
times where like
i remember my first year here like it
was after i'd gotten back from montreal
after i did montreal and i came back
from that and was just like
i'm on top of the world and then one of
the first show big shows back just
after everyone knew i was at montreal
and like it was like well
[ __ ] there's resolve being tested right
away but anyway point being
i'm gone point being uh if you think you
can take this ship
off course you ain't met me yet better
yeah i love it it's off course friday
what's special what is shot ben coming
in what are we talking about this is
something completely different but
anyway i'm sorry guys no this is it
let's uh
no questions i just wanted to know like
so once you started to become successful
at comedy and your parents saw that you
were putting an effort towards something
and you kind of grounded yourself a
little bit yeah that kind of smoothed
the relationship over then
oh and i also apologize i also had many
drunken teary-eyed
[ __ ] apologies to my parents and like
and like they come to shows and like
but i think my my dad definitely finds
me funny
my mom however thinks i
am god's gift to comedy okay it's insane
and my mom and i and i all my life
growing up i always thought i got my
sense of humor from my dad because he's
a p you know he's a [ __ ]
runs of business very present charming
[ __ ] in the moment snappy god
but my mom i've learned is where i get
my sense of i get my like
i get i guess i get my not my lack of
stage fright from my dad yeah
but charisma yeah my [ __ ] sense of
humor comes from my mother
who is a twisted woman really and it's
[ __ ] hilarious like my dad
had a cancer he had a tumor
basically in his [ __ ] and he was
[ __ ] blood
which is terrible right yeah but when my
mom broke the news to us she's like
he just won't stop shedding blood i mean
and my mom's my mom's uh she's a
delivery labor delivery nurse
she's like i mean i've i i haven't seen
this much blood come out of a human's
being's crush
you know all my whole [ __ ] she's like
rickles all this stuff just busting his
[ __ ]
balls and like she i mean he would thank
god he got it removed and everything's
fine now but like
in the moment we're all terrified my
mom's just cracking jokes
daniel and so she they come to every
show they can
it's fantastic that's a good that's a
great that's a [ __ ] great are you
garbage story right there
after all that the whole thing comes
full circle yeah yeah
i had to become i had to be i had like i
said recyclable
because the thing was like you know not
to talk heavy on comedy but like being a
comedian that's such a reach
and like that you know it's not like
you're getting a regular job like oh
well sean got everything together he
went four years at school
and now he's in a you know what i mean
you [ __ ] went for a big thing
and [ __ ] achieved it yeah so you know
what i mean it's it's
like yeah it's a special thing my
sister's got my sister has her masters
in sociology
you know my other sister's like in
culinary chef you know
world and my brother is a surgical tech
so they've all got like real kareem he's
not the one who's like
but you know but still but like you know
this pandemics made it all [ __ ]
harder for everyone
i mean it's it's i've never been more
career-wise terrified than i am now just
because
we don't know but we all are still
pushing through mm-hmm
but uh resolve this resolve testing your
god damn it you're [ __ ] good at this
resistance it's testing our resolve
that's why he's fatso of kipi and the
fatso and we'll be right back after
these
messages from geritol everybody all
right
that was incredible thank you we're
gonna play a little game called are you
garbage
please all right uh we're gonna ask you
a series of questions to determine
the trashiness now we celebrate some of
it we don't celebrate all
you know other parts of it um some
standard questions
first thing we want to ask you is what
street you grew up on now things
that would be garbage would be like a
throughway
you know we're looking for a circle
we're looking for oh i got
a court oh what do you got
westport court okay oh wait don't all
three parts of that are not there that's
port court i got it here's here's the
here's and here's the uh
the sidecar part cul-de-sac nice nice
that was cul-de-sac kid too
that's upper upper middle class they you
know commit the basketball court in the
calder
the basketball not the court the uh the
net that was just for everyone
dude if you have my because like i go
back to my my parents still live in this
that's when you know you live in a good
neighborhood yeah they still live in the
same house they're still
the same house and they live in the end
of kosak and now the kids who are like
the general they're like
i don't know they're like 14 now or
whatever they have like we had when we
were all kids oh yeah and now the new
kids have one i'm like
[ __ ] all right you still you know we
still got a couple of bucks down here
yeah
i mean when if it's a la costa if it's a
lacrosse goal
or like a soccer net you're like all
right this is interesting yeah it might
be a little more money here but a
basketball goal that's standard yeah
you know we had that we had a basketball
court in a driveway my brother built the
lacrosse net in the backyard there you
go yeah i thought it was pretty sweet
but when i was home for the
during the pandemic you know i noticed
there's like a new wave of kids in the
neighborhood
yeah and i looked down my parents street
and they had the basketball net you know
with like the sand in the bottom of it
yeah yeah they had that out on the
street now they're all playing and i was
just like
same thing you just look at him you're
like these kids are going to be all
right one day
can i can i just say really quickly one
one of the only positive things to come
from this whole crown of our situation
is getting to repeatedly hear people
from the east coast say the word
pandemic
pandemic they hang out the a and the
endemic is quick
them and endemic comes with a whole
posse
pandemic
[Music]
i was down i spent the quarantine down
in wildwood new jersey which is like
everybody from philadelphia goes to the
jersey shore ohio what is the trashiest
one
okay it's so it's a it's they call it
the irish riviera it's just land of like
[ __ ]
a lot of union dudes it's all plumbers
it's all like if you
if you're a plumber or a pipe fitter you
can afford a short house a lot of irish
pubs on the beach
oh yeah or if you had a good slip and
fall case yeah
yeah yeah uh or yeah so
we're down at the boards there's this
woman there's a woman who look you know
like
she's just this big tattoos on the arm
loud [ __ ]
blue and she goes what the [ __ ] is an
annie body anyway
and i was like is that she goes does
that mean you got it
you don't got it who the [ __ ] knows and
i was like
oh man you might drop that hardcore
freak oh yeah
i i fall back in no jesus who the [ __ ]
even knows i thought i was an episode of
the wire if we could dye his hair we
could put him undercover down in
northeast florida i i i can go wow
dude that mid-atlantic that is such a
mystery accent to me
yeah that's what chile baltimore's
thicker than
philly oh baltimore i know it's trashier
than philly yeah
what do you think's the trashiest of
what of all the accidents in america
oh dude the [ __ ] hmm you got philly
you got boston
midwest for me it's always going to be
the gulf coast accent
yeah it's like a sloppy sort of southern
kind of dirt
i like that though that's so charming
like like like
i said i said in a bit but like a new a
true new orleans accent sounds like a
[ __ ] brooklyn
like take like a [ __ ] brooklyn union
delegate all right
and give that guy a couple valium slow
him down you know once he's now he's all
[ __ ] up and he's just kind of talking
and he just kind of doesn't give a [ __ ]
that's so that's a real new orleans
accent she saw like
a drunk guy from bensonhurst they don't
[ __ ] care
but then like to get the gulf coast it's
just a sloppy sort of high-pitched night
like a nasally
i like it like and then like and then of
course you get to like park then throw
in some mississippi twang to it a little
bit and it's just sort of like a
it sounds like someone whose nose is
broken and they got a sinus affection at
the same
time you know but but it's trashy and
like a
charming yeah it's charming yeah yeah i
always thought the southern accent
i lived in north carolina for a little
bit i thought that even like the guys
that were like the dirtiest of the dirty
when they talked they still sounded
educated to me oh yeah i don't know why
you're an idiot i mean i i will trust
just based off of like meeting
appearances i will trust someone with a
shitty trashy accent
than someone with a refined
i also think it's what you know more
like i'm more accustomed to hearing like
yes what are you doing later so i'm like
i innately trust this guy rather than
like what do you do you know like
something more proper like what are you
up to yeah i'm like you sound like a
lawyer or a doctor or someone has
authority over me
yeah guys a cop yeah i mean because
there's no i don't know
what like the trashy west coast accent
is it's probably like the surfer maybe
i'm sure like out in the desert's got
something
it's f it's funny that accent when you
hear people there's a guy
i won't say his name he's a boston comic
but he he
is a boston guy but he has like [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] turtle like southern
california
really it's like what how the [ __ ] did
that possible how did that happen
yeah how did you grow up in the [ __ ]
woosh or like worcester you know like
[ __ ] pronounce worcester actually but
actually
[Applause]
so whatever you go to duncan whatever
yeah oh man
i'm um so we got the
the street out of the way another big
one is what was the name and i assume
you she said it's upper middle class
neighborhood so i assume it was going to
be nice
it was the name of the grocery store
that your mom went to as a kid
shwagman's
it sounds garbage is it nice though or
is it they were all
similar okay there were the
like a guy any anyone from louisiana
what do you mean schwegman sounds right
nick
swegman that ain't knock off that's good
eating down there squiggly
though schwegman's got good [ __ ] though
dude wegmans literally sounds like
something from snl
we're going and it could be anything you
could have swagman's grocery store
schwegman's uh go-kart schweitman's mini
golf
uh schwegman's attorney at law uh which
is i think what they have no then
then john schwegman well then it became
no dylan says no he's a southern guy oh
is it trashy
win dixie yeah you remember when dixie
yeah i never would ever step foot in a
window
you would never shop for my family yeah
well then you would never be mrs patton
where are you gonna get your wine
coolers dylan how are you gonna [ __ ]
load up the van
publix with an x you [ __ ] i don't like
that either publix yeah that's
oh i'm sorry yeah all class no but yeah
so that winn-dixie okay ultimately and
finally the
the last one would be uh what's the
local gas station
now just so you know something that
you'd want to stay away from would be
like a golf
a luke oil oh you know you want some you
want something especially being down
there
if i if either if you know what this is
i'm gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] my pants
actually do it it was a place called
time saver
i don't know sounds all right though
because who is the gas company i was a
supplier i wanted to ship my pants a
little bit um
i don't know it was just time saver was
a big thing
in the south it was just a red triangle
it's a time saver and
that's where i got my hot fries oh
that's where wait you mean they're andy
capps oh yeah dude that [ __ ]
really you're an andy capps guy i was a
handicapped guy
oh that's a first here hot fries dude
[Laughter]
if you've had them within the past three
years they're still stuck in your teeth
for sure yeah yeah
and there's a drink that i think is
pretty much only in louisiana it's
called big shot
which is which is basically just faygo
2.0 but
pre-dates faygo what's faygo that's like
the
thing saying clown posse it's like
flavored [ __ ] soup it's basically
high fructose corn syrup it's like a
sugar like a fan yeah
yeah but even more extreme i think and
they used to have
pineapple pineapple there was a there
was a spot
oh also pineapple [ __ ] soda big
handicaps
and hot sauce dude the fact that that's
garbage
people wonder why i needed new teeth
last year
do you have all fresh ones these are new
yeah yeah i got them last year
damn i just had to i'd [ __ ] tortured
my fronts
for decades cracking beer bottles i
wanted a fresh set you
dental insurance is a hoax it exists
that's [ __ ]
yeah um but yeah pineapple big shot big
[ __ ] large bag
they only sell them in the fall bags you
can't yeah maybe you could get the
little one some places yeah but somebody
was saying they pack them in there too
somebody handicapped doesn't skimp on
them i don't like fritos
i don't know if it was on twitter or
wherever that or reddit or somebody in
one of the discussions
for the show they were talking about how
they're
it's an inherently trash snack because
you can only buy them at gas stations
yeah
they don't sell them at like the
supermarket right it's only at gas
stations can you buy [ __ ]
was this big to you or was that was what
the hot fries a thing down there hot
fries is [ __ ] everywhere yeah dude
hot fries but here
here's what's [ __ ] insane about fries
are all over cause you should because i
agree it's a trashy thing
but it's inspired by a cartoon right
a cartoon that is british wow now i'm
not saying british people aren't trash
but andy capp when you read that cartoon
you probably read him in whatever local
accent but in reality he's like all
right then
hey mom yeah and going down to the store
going to bed on the horses
his wife was always breaking his balls
right classic wife
you know that transcends culture
and then excuse me i've seen this
everywhere but like wrapper chips
oh the hot dog the uh [ __ ] are they
called the though i know what you're
talking about
honey snacks rap snacks that was the
first place i saw those was that uh
like still big rappers today are still
doing [ __ ] yeah that'd be
if you're a rapper and you get your well
now it's like it now it's like a novelty
thing it's like oh i got rap snacks
what do you think about the trend that
like rappers are now making creating
their own meals at mcdonald's
because i've had is that for real well
they signed on what's his name it was
one guy
what's no there's another travis scott
yeah now somebody else is doing it
travis scott every time i'm like that's
not a country star
every time you hear that name like and
that's not a country singer that's a
rapper yeah i mean
that's the biggest one he makes a pretty
good quarter pounder yeah i'll try it no
this is way around the griddle
i'm in all right i got one here let's
see oh since we're talking about uh
you know languages and stuff does anyone
in your family pronounce it lie
barry no i will say that because in the
promo for
our show i pronounce a library library i
get trashed every [ __ ] week but the
new orleans accent would
force you to say like library library
whenever people people get pissed at me
when i get pissed at them for saying
nollins
because that's like the [ __ ] some
some [ __ ] real estate agent from
kansas city invented that pronunciation
no new orleans bastion no
the way true new orleans would say would
be new orleans
new orleans new orleans so you say you
the new gifts sink it in the middle
new orleans new orleans sunken just like
the city itself
sinking for new orleans but the
the new orleans accent is in the [ __ ]
except it's in the nasal
new orleans okay nine my my
my area code growing up was 985. the way
someone from louisiana would say it is
985. you hear that 985.
all the eyes are kind of also o's yeah
95. yeah all in no 985 dude
all right sorry but yeah no no libraries
okay you currently wear a robe
[ __ ] yeah yeah you're a rogue guy [ __ ]
yeah dude
robes hurt okay you gotta wear nothing
you gotta get you gotta wear nothing
underneath the clothes
depends on the robe what kind of what
are we talking about i mean we're
talking just a standard
[ __ ] target robe but i mean i'm i'm
the put on my robe
[ __ ] air force ones with no socks
walk down the store
you know with a mask on really to get
orange juice
uh they don't know i'm not wearing
anything underneath it
oh that's trash walking down yeah you're
going to the bodega i'm going to be
rolling i'm going to break yeah yeah
yeah you're going to a brooklyn bodega
in your robe
yeah i only did this once but but i went
still if you thought about it i was like
i want i woke up i was hungover i wanted
orange juice for some reason more than
[ __ ] anything oh man when you want an
oj
yeah and there's a spot you know at the
end of my block i was like [ __ ] it
robe air force one's no socks
put a mask on wallet phone in my hands
like
that's dude nobody seemed to give a [ __ ]
that was great
that's yeah insane that might have been
that that's like if i had
a poor card that's the one that's a
tough one to come back from that's a d
yeah you're not going to pull that up by
the end of the market period i'll tell
you that
uh okay will you take leftovers home
from a restaurant [ __ ] yeah
that's perfectly normal no it's trash
what yeah
what yes trash extract
you finish it at the restaurant you
finish it or you don't finish it you're
paying for an experience
you're not taking the food home with
[ __ ] out you're paying to be served
you're paying for an experience
we never talked about this i don't know
what this guy's talking about he's on
the [ __ ] d-pad yeah most of our
listeners are trash i'm also trashed i'm
not saying i'm trapped
i say lie berry i am trash are you i
i feel like you're a prince who's been
lied to this whole time
you don't mean you don't take the
leftovers
i'm trash does your wife let you get
away with this what do you mean get away
with it if you don't finish the meal
first of all i'm finishing the meal i'm
a [ __ ] grown man i'm finishing my
meal
that's crazy i'm finishing the meal i
mean that's a good point
who's not what grown man is going out to
dinner and not finishing him i love
everything about leftovers i loved when
my parents would go to dinner when i was
a kid
and they would bring home leftovers oh
yeah dude
big fan of the brought home leftovers oh
my god also you're trying to re-cook a
steak that some guy
drinking cook i'm eating it right there
i'm in the [ __ ] together
cold i cannot warm up leftovers no
trash it's trash i'll take it they're
not gonna do that trash
yeah they don't [ __ ] know a guy i
didn't know this
yeah it's trash dude yeah you think you
know seriously
you're paying for an experience you're
like oh these two strips of steak are
mine i'm taking these with me
it's like dude either eat it or don't
eat it next week join in next week with
our host h foley and sean pat
kevin ryan rode his yacht back
back to the palace age drove his jersey
turnpike wait i mean
i will say this no leftovers five times
out of ten
with leftovers in new york i will give
them to a homeless person i'll give them
a hope classic
i will give i'll take it i'll give you
guys i will
i will see a hobo on the way and even
sometimes it's the hobo just like
a lot of times just the guy who's
sleeping i'll just put it down all right
i think he's going to see it you know i
got all right so let's let's
cross the street in front of me
i don't do that dotted line like a
treasure
map it's like hey i think he's going to
have fun too
no i'll give it to someone that's great
that's a classmate that is a class move
all right so let's paint this
let's say you're out on a date you're
out on a first date with a woman you
know
your second date early date you go out
to a steakhouse are you taking
leftovers home with her there there that
that that
i gotta say is no you don't thank you
first date because you don't want to
look like a [ __ ] jerk first date
you're going out to dinner off the jump
you have
drinks no no no see then you take her
out all right so
second date you're going out you're
still trying to impress this girl you're
gonna go
oh can i can i get the half of the baked
potato wrapped up
you ready no you're not do you want to
take you want to take that home with you
you want to take it home yeah you give
her the offer
yeah do you want to take that hey do you
and if she says no then what do you say
oh i'll take it also let me get some of
his over there we should see other
people
yeah also on a first date you do not
you order less food yeah you know you're
gonna eat you're not going ahead it
doesn't matter on the order it's what
will you put yourself in a position to
look like a [ __ ] don't you don't
first date you don't you're not doing
enough to where there's gonna be a
leftover
regardless if there was leftovers oh she
would not ask no and i
also i also make it a point every time
i've said this on another podcast i have
always
farted in front of the girl on the phone
on the first place
i don't know what they're getting right
away i don't know there it is there's
the
a pheromones b uh i'm human this guy's
getting you from every angle it is you
know
i don't know and and it's never like a
hey excuse me and just
sit down i sit on a lap i don't like i
hold my finger yeah i'll do it while i'm
like helping a child
or like is got a burning building hold
on he was so sweet he took the leftovers
and brought them to a homeless guy
but then he farted in the guy's face i
think he [ __ ] himself in the cabin while
i'm opening the door
it's a heavy door i apologize someone
step on a duck
yeah uh this is a this is one that i
that we've talked about
i just like thought of it uh last night
because my girlfriend commented that i
do it and my dad does it
are you when you eat are you a bite and
then a sip
guy or do you eat and then drink your
drink after
definitely bite bite and sipper yeah
that's see that's garbage
me too yeah wait why
because you're it's you're mixing like
one more because i do it yeah so i'm
pretty sure
if we're both doing it it's not but i
thought no no no
because i thought the whole idea like
it's it's a spanish thing with wine like
you're supposed to everything it goes
with so like yeah it's weird with it
it's not like you know it's not
not a [ __ ] big shot that's maybe a
nice mailbag
that that's just to melt the ice caps of
chewed handicap
but but like dude it's like caulk when
it gets in there
and you also are you also sub-question
are you a multiple
item on the fork guy piece of meatloaf
piece of mashed potato piece piece of
no pete real no no i'm a like dude i am
the most
i also had a mom that would just
straight up after
one warning stop chomping which meant
chomping is chewing with your mouth open
okay all right one warning and then it
was a hand to the back of the head nice
no no chip so like i grew i grew up like
you chew with your [ __ ] mouth yeah at
the table like we might have been
[ __ ] animals everywhere else but at
the table
it was tighten it up you belch at a
table that's two weeks of your life
damn i like unconsciously you know what
i mean like
get up like it was a thing like if
you're going to belch get up walk away
go into the kitchen go in the other room
shot come on but if you did it at the
table you were [ __ ] wow that's good
class man i also prefer to eat with
utensils straight up
i just do i'm just like i'm supposed to
i know like even a sandwich i just like
getting [ __ ] on my face and
i'm just put it down i do the movie last
minute it is classic i eat very classy
wow i also get grossed out too will you
cut a burger
no i'll eat a burger but i'll eat a
burger like a [ __ ] like little i'm a
little bite guy
i've started to take the top of the
sandwich or burger off take the bun
eat that like just knock that down yeah
you saw me dylan saw me do this like a
gerbil
and then eat the eat eat the eat the
rest of it with a fork and a knife like
you don't make an open face sandwich out
of it i mean that's that
i see i say that that's classy okay i'll
get yeah i don't think it's
trashy yeah usually we'll make a
coleslaw sandwich out of the top of the
bun though i mean that's hard
that's that's trash dude if you're
turning if you're going to a restaurant
and turning one meal to two meals
that's [ __ ] trash two sandwiches i
don't i i i shave look
i get some more mayo and uh you know
what else is freaking you send over to
the table it's like
the native americans you use every part
of the buffalo
use every part of sandwich are you
calling native americans trash
no
intended if you're breaking it down and
making second sammies
if i did everything like the chef
intended i would only want to eat one
scallop
on a mountain of cauliflower puree i
would not be having my handicaps with a
big shot i tell you that much
all right we got a few more this is a
hot apple hot
hot hot temperature okay
nice pause uh have you ever owned a
hacky sack
[ __ ] yeah yeah multiple yeah ever been
to a mighty mighty boston's concert
no okay i just laugh because i know
a fellow comedian guy who writes for
kimmel named brian cook
very funny guy extremely funny guy uh he
he goes to the mighty mighty boss tones
every single year he's the house they're
the house band aren't they or new year's
eve no i don't know
but he sees him every year on new year's
eve in boston oh that's pretty cool
but i think the mighty muddy bluffstones
are the house band for jimmy kimmel
aren't they no it's the roots oh for
kimmel no it's not kimmel no no
no no somebody i don't know i think
you're wrong
all right um growing up did any of your
family's cars ever have a beaded seat
cover
no actually no beaded seat cover
covers i wouldn't take the van i know
you'd think but nah just
never that i i always looked at that as
too exotic
for really the the suburbs i always
it's a very camp driver thing i always
pegged it for like
a shia it's like trying to cover up a
shitty seat like instead of like really
fixing it or cleaning you're like i just
throw these [ __ ] wooded beans
what do i need bees for when you got
duct tape
or any kind of tape do you currently
have any skin tags or cysts
i uh i don't but i have had uh skin tag
removed before
did you remove it yourself or go to the
doctor doc dermatologist he's not animal
i snip him off with the toenail clipper
jesus christ
dude i don't i think that you're just
savage now yeah yeah
he's at a different level matters savage
he is a different level of animal i'm
not paying a copayment here all of a
sudden you're
perfectly good toenail clippers in my
apartment you're gonna break my foot
you're gonna break my stones over
[ __ ] take it or
leftovers meanwhile you're clipping your
pieces your body off we're gonna talk
about that
yeah it's gonna be that's gonna be a
meeting that's an ayg meeting
um if you were if you were to go to your
parents house now i guess or even back
then was there ever hand lotion next to
the sink
like really that's clay that's so classy
it's that classic yeah yeah we didn't
see lotion in my house
until at least 2005.
you know there's no location i know it's
classy because growing up we never had
it it went to my mom's house last
weekend
she has it now because they came into a
little bit of cash so she's got it and
she's spending she's got lotion money
okay well then can i just say this then
ask this counter question what if it's
the same
bottle from 1998. now hold on yeah
kevin didn't explain that right yeah
kevin i think was looking for
a nice pump yeah correct yeah you're
talking about like you gotta flip it and
yeah like like trash like a jergens
bottle just set now
there's gotta be some pump action on it
no i'm talking pump yeah my parents now
have three a set
it's hey
we're having fun that's a comedy podcast
it's hand soap lotion and something else
what could the third thing be
hot sauce i don't know what the
imitation shutter
it's movie butter you never know when
you're going to end up in the bathroom
and you got oh i got my toast with me
[Laughter]
i was carrying this around it's my
bathroom toast yeah
ah clip and bite your nails oh
man i was i was a biter for a long
[ __ ] time nothing's bad but now i'm a
clipper
never in public oh
sean [ __ ] if i saw you if i see you
clipping your nose
clipping my nails yeah no never in
public i
only only only clip in the shower okay
there was no not even in my brain only
in the shower only in the shower wait
wait
what do you do with the clippings they
go down the [ __ ] drain i'm okay with
that
clipping your nails in the chat they're
they're softer you're always supposed to
do
their jackets i you only do it after you
wash your hair because you're [ __ ]
soaping them up you're cleaning it's
pretty good it's very interesting
follow-up this is a hot button issue
here at uh
[ __ ] baldi in the fatso yeah
well you've had the baldy
[Laughter]
um i'm more of a power bottom uh do you
uh brush your teeth in the shower no wow
toothbrushing is a separate yes thank
you because i'm because i'm a big
electric toothbrush guy
so i mean i might just right there tell
you what the gun what brand is it what
brand you got
to be sticking only except the lancers
oral b
sonic care sonicare i hear that quip is
doing pretty good yeah i knew somebody
that had a sony
i swear to god what's going on
i've never seen it before in my life but
they had a sony toothbrush
all you gotta do is grow up with an ant
who has halitosis
and you will never not brush your
[ __ ] things as a kid are you a
mouthwash guy
yes listerine listerine the gold do you
think oh my god
what the [ __ ]
i imagine you look like i imagine i just
i felt like the movie screen
during the during the showing of the
sixth sense
when you were the entire audience when
they realized he'd been dead the whole
time
oh my god yeah yeah i use the yes
you don't hear that a lot i used to
because i like the [ __ ] bitter
stinging burn you do oh i love that [ __ ]
that's some deep-seated issues you've
got going on right there
this guy's psycho yeah i get a little
more interesting then i burn myself
sometimes
sometimes i will brush really quickly
the inside of my cheeks
so that when i do the mouthwash and i go
we go like that
oh yeah it burns in your [ __ ] cheeks
killing those
psychos [ __ ] germs down yes please
something well i do
you have to really wash your mouth after
you eat human flesh you know what i
mean cannibalism it's true it's true
something that i've been doing more
lately but i've always done it is i
don't feel like i don't feel satisfied
with brushing my teeth
until i make myself gag a little bit
with the toothbrush everybody else do
that because you got to get your [ __ ]
back into the back of the tongue i don't
feel like i got it oh dude i get the
tongue big time
do a tongue scraper but sometimes it
backfires if i eat late the night before
and i do that in the morning
i'll [ __ ] start throwing up
[ __ ] please that's a perfectly timed
drop right there
jesus christ sometimes he's you say
things and i don't know i don't know
where to go buddy
i tell you what fat kid's always funny
one man
real quickly i just want to say i just
now everything on that wall is in my
apartment
in my apartment currently no but direct
car noir
oh also trash all right my mom won't
know my mom my mom
here's just car noir my mom years ago i
was like for christmas and my birthday
was like stop buying me things
like i don't like i don't need [ __ ] i
travel a lot thank you so much but like
give it to the you know
don't buy it for the grant her grandkids
my nieces but every year she gives me
bags of travel toiletries just
because i travel so much and a lot of
dracar noir
and max body spray oh anyway which can
help in a pinch
maybe but it's tough i am now officially
a full cologne guy by the way i started
this year christmas
we went home to my girlfriend's place
and her aunt got me like the little
really cause you wouldn't guess by that
shirt
i like to keep you know the duality of
man
you like i like to stimulate your old
factory sensors
as much as your visual
but they got me like a little sample of
all different kinds of phones and now
i've settled on one
i want to do wd-40
[Laughter]
all right have you ever taken a couch or
any other piece of furniture from the
trash mr patton
uh yeah table oh only only heart nothing
soft
okay table chairs desk but never
lamp lamp new york or was it new york
yeah
new york trash is tough trash how do you
get bed bugs brother
well never beds no anything how stupid
that was my responsibility no
i didn't take beds i'm not a [ __ ]
idiot i don't think anybody i'm taking
i'm taking this nightstand and this
comforter but not a mattress
i did that with the chair right there
jeans whatever yeah yeah yeah
yeah i've i've rolled the dice on that
i've i've gone i've raw dogged some
furniture you know
i just made my skin curl uh speaking of
raw dog
what's the wiping situation do you go
front to back
body both both yeah wait you go in
you go top you go top of the butt crack
down
i go i go front to back first right
back to front up back to front second
front to back third three white pull
reel yeah no standing up there
absolutely staying up the whole time
wait so you poop and then stand up and
then start your wiping process
poop stand up but over the toilet yeah
like spring you can't hover
your joints can't handle you you gotta
lean you're not a [ __ ]
catcher what are you talking about no
yeah like stan like yeah [ __ ]
reposition legs stand kind of directly
over the toilet
white in and out in and out and down up
okay for a while i don't know why but
i went inside i went through like i'm
calling the signs
giving him the high heat curveball here
from foley i rash i wish i would give
her the
wipe don't wipe don't worry always shake
it off
don't forget what what's your i think
what you're looking for is going bidet
but they got yeah which which by the way
i am i don't have one
but i've tried it there's one here in
the studio [ __ ] lovable
and i i took it i told you i've used it
i took one here and i didn't know i
didn't know it just
self-activates buddy that thing starts
going it's blowing the whole
whole thing's happening down there there
nothing i gave her my phone number will
get you up in the morning
like than a hot blast of water to the
actual yeah or cold
depending on the temperature how the
weekend went
we call that a middle class bidet
blue collar bidet a blue collar it's a
gatorade bottle with the
what the [ __ ] is that the loopty
loop-de-loops the sports
the sport straw whatever the big flexi
just blast it
what about uh what's your level of hot
dog garbage okay as far as making hot
dogs
how do you prepare a hot dog i'm gonna
say this right off the jump
uh i do i do feel that every hot dog is
inferior to the chicago style hot dog
i do actually feel that way i love a
chica and i come from new orleans where
they got the lucky dog which is a
massive
[ __ ] forearm of a hot dog and it's
great
but i i love a shitty disgusting
like cardiac arrest inducing chili dog
okay but the chicago hot every time i go
to chicago i usually eat nothing but
chicago hot dogs for the first
24 hours but that's that's a prepared
thing i'm talking about cooking
oh boil boils the trashiest or the
fanciest that's the way i go no matter
what
so so call it what you will i will i
don't microwave put a name on it i don't
i'll grill it if there's a grill
situation but if i'm just like making
hot dogs for myself boil in water in a
pan
interesting or a pot i like a boy i like
a plump
juicy [ __ ] they are nice yeah i mean
yeah it's disgusting
apartments things like hot dogs tough i
get it you know
it's a tough situation then you go
outside find the nearest uh
kid on a [ __ ] on one of those hover
scooters throw the hot dog water at him
keep him on his [ __ ] toes stain your
toes yeah
uh if you're throwing hot dog water on
people you're [ __ ]
dreaded or at least fantasizing about it
also true that qualifies as well you
know what i do i actually load up my
bidet tank with the old hot dog
yellow flavoring i got a self-sustaining
ecosystem over there
forget about it kippy what do you got
i think i only got one or two more here
let's see what did you call the game
where you knocked on someone's door and
ran away
i mean i can't say that
i didn't even think of that really we
can't say that we didn't call it that
but that was
what it was called yeah i but uh
but but later and uh as you those of us
who were like yeah you probably
shouldn't say it yeah
tend to call ladder ding dong ding dong
ditches is acceptable or which was
which is [ __ ] ridiculous i don't know
why but we used to call it see the witch
see the witch i don't ever heard that
that's scary because there's no one
there because witches don't exist yeah
that sort of thing was like oh i'm gonna
see the witch's [ __ ] he just knocked on
the door
and run that he's caught a knock and run
yeah knocking i mean
to the point right right you know yeah
y'all won't go knocking run down out
down here
philadelphia was a little more pragmatic
you know what i mean
i'm gonna knock it and i'm gonna run
wall and she had to be a little more
poetic
[ __ ] a little more intellectual crowd
huh yeah oh yeah yeah
the weirdest one is knock knock zoom
zoom what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] nerds
if you guessed me
yeah there's that from the inside of the
locker that's [ __ ] nerd [ __ ] right
there yeah yeah
foley still fully still wants to be the
tough guy from an 80s movie so bad
yeah whatever dork yeah give you a
wedgie nerd oh we got to ask you these
before we let you get out of here i
[ __ ]
i'll ask me as many as you want uh
number one uh you open a box you open a
bottle of ketchup where does it go in
the fridge or in the cabinet
fridge now here's a second back up to
that question ask me
how in the fridge how upside down yeah
he's a [ __ ] gentleman wow
yeah nobody's ever said the position of
the body i always thought that was kind
of
if it gets even like half less than
halfway you go up to your story
if you don't to me you're not if you
don't keep ketchup in the [ __ ] fridge
and i take that personally even if i've
never met you what about your syrup
where do you keep that after you've
opened it
syrup i think can stay outside keep a
little warm so it's not it's not [ __ ]
just
thick yeah and what do you think butter
goes on the counter or in the fridge
in a goddamn fridge okay conflicting
views on that but
all right all right now yeah i i've
recently turned
it's very rare that we turn our own
opinions on here but i was turned to go
butter off the counter as the classier
thing
off the counter but on the counter i'm
sorry actually i'm gonna give this a go
you might have just turned me on the
boat
because so it's got but it's gotta be
salted butter so it'll preserve
out the problem is if it's on just out
i'm gonna just take a spoonful of it
i know myself i just love butter and i
always just
that is a problem if i have a problem
with it no it's [ __ ] butter butter's
fantastic i'll give it great
my my girlfriend has an addiction like
an un
uh peanut butter it's the most insane
[ __ ] i've ever seen like she can't
it's an uncontrollable like if there's a
jar of peanut butter
she will inevitably just grab it and
straight spoon the mouth dude big spoon
the jar yeah yeah dude a big spoon of
that and some [ __ ] mods apple juice
back in the day
that was a [ __ ] party in my house
yeah i mean that's a party in anyone's
house
apple juice and peanut butter jam baby
oh man yeah um yeah that's it for me
final question let's do it growing up
was it normal for your parents to serve
you
milk with dinner absolutely not
wow okay i will say though
it was normal for at least i'm gonna say
twice a month
my parents to uh just completely
both be too busy to cook dinner
and just show up with like grab bags
full of
full of uh like taco bell oh or it was
it was nine times out of ten taco bell
just be like oh mom and dad come here
later and just come in two [ __ ] one
bag full of bean burritos one full of
chicken sauce tacos go to town
wow so i that's like the milk with
dinner
that's true yeah but still i mean if
it's not like if it's you know if it's
not [ __ ] three days a week
no it was twice a month but it was
always taco bell
which is why i still to this day taco
bell's a treat
is your go-to uh of okay
arby's wendy's taco bell that's my top
three what
that's my three wives i've heard that oh
my god
my mount rushmore of fast food is arby's
taco bell
wendy's ooh chick-fil-a
wow no i'm taking chick-fil-a [ __ ]
what nah guys
one not number one no number one is taco
bell number two is wendy's
so taco bell i don't think i've ever
heard arby's making a top three
ever taco bell is my lincoln all right
arby's is what jefferson okay uh i mean
i'm sorry uh wendy's jefferson arby's is
yeah arby's is third whoever third is
and then i chick-fil-a but also like i
get i don't like their waffle fries
if i have to if i have to like right now
choose fourth on the what route mount
rushmore
i'm gonna go church's chicken which is a
rare it's hard to find a church
guys it's hard to find a church's
chicken but god damn it that shit's
delicious damn
wow sean patton an enigma wrapped in a
riddle
but trash wrapped in a waffle fry yeah
right in a bean burrito i'm going trash
i mean
growing is a guy his parents want a
tight ship
clearly got the southern hospitality
other manners
you know the [ __ ] mailbox smashing
you got the
you got the [ __ ] going to the going to
the bodega and his [ __ ]
robe yep i mean he's got rvs on his
[ __ ] mount rushmore fast food what
are we doing
i tell you what but trash means you've
lived that's right oh
baby of course let's celebrate and we'll
consult celebrate it yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah thank you so much for
your connor's all mine
uh anything you want the folks out there
to know anything you got coming up
anything you want to plug lay it on us
uh you could hear my podcast it's called
five words
it's on the all things comedy network
and uh
uh you can buy my album it's called
scuttlebutt
it is on uh helium records but anywhere
you could buy albums
nice yeah and by the way before you
leave i have to tell you because we talk
about this
all the time i wasn't even there i hear
it second hand
and it's one of the it's like one of the
funny stories it was maybe a few years
ago you were doing uh
what was it comedy juice or something
like that one night and you were at
gotham i got them
all right it was like a week night you
were doing some showcase show were we
downstairs
no you were upstairs place was packed it
was hot and you just did this perfect
move
i think it was me and chris cotton if it
wasn't him it was me and cotton standing
in the back
and we both fell over laughing but you
did the move because you know how it has
like an open stage
yeah you walked up you waved like high
like you were going to the mic and then
you just kept going down the other side
of this
you had [ __ ] a huge boom
and then the second you got to be on
that stage you got another boom and we
still talk about it for this day we
thought it was awesome
we love you buddy thanks appreciate it
that was that gotham
yeah hope it reopens it yeah
i mean the ceiling's tall enough to be
ventilated it's true
i didn't think of that it was [ __ ]
built to have a goddamn
hot air balloon fans in there thank you
guys for having me thank you thank you
so much fun appreciate it what do you
got to tell them uh just as always make
sure you
review subscribe on itunes and to keep
us in the top 2 hundo
get on it uh full episodes available
on youtube you can subscribe there as
well and again if you want to subscribe
to gas digital network you can use promo
code ayg
we make a couple of bucks you save a
couple of bucks it's a win-win so do it
we appreciate all the support guys yes
we have a lot of special things coming
up that you guys are gonna love
uh just to say it again if you
won the contest the t-shirts have been
ordered we're gonna get them out to you
very soon and we love you
peace peace